I want you I want all of you forever
okay so we always knew Ryan Gosling was
a romantic but this takes it to a whole
new level et has learned that the 35
year olds actor whisked Eva Mendes away
to celebrate her 42nd birthday and we
have two photos Ryan took his ladylove
to Palm Springs for a four-day stay at
the vacation home by Frank Sinatra and a
landmark like that doesn't come cheap
Ryan rented the gorgeous house at $2,600
a night that means that their getaway
cost over ten thousand dollars I'm in
love with her and I don't know what to
do about it
as always the pair with Loki and
daughter
Esmeralda join them look here Ava in the
backseat probably with her little one as
Ryan drives a Sora's table et that they
kept things quiet and romantic during
her stay only stepping out to pick up
takeout from restaurants and because
Ryan is oh so perfect he also jumped out
of his car at one point to save a dog
after noticing the owner chasing his pup
on the loose I mean can we please just
talk about how sweet Ryan is head over
to Twitter send me a tweet with all of
your thoughts and I'll see you next time